[Musique]
cet homme est une légende
son histoire est incroyable
et pourtant
essayez donc avec nous de ne pas y
croire
par rapport à vous je suis immortel mais
de fait je ne suis pas aussi mortel j'ai
un temps donnée qui est très grand qui
correspond à
certainement plusieurs milliers d'années
mais qui est un temps imparti kampala
chacun dans preneur
je suis né un jour oui
il y a dix sept mille ans
[Musique]
tout en lui autour de lui hélas pour
surprendre il s'entoure de prodiges et
il se fait fort de réaliser le rêve des
alchimistes fabriquer de l'or
c'est ce que vous appelez la pierre
philosophale
la proposition
voulez vous prendre le monstre plomb et
le trompait ont trompé l'extrémité dans
le monde c'est tout
merci il a très peu où
il y en a beaucoup trop
elle permettait de le creuser
refermez le poser
lemay
le fil de plomb c'est nous qui l'avons
apporter il n'a fourni que le creuset
nous l'avons examiné soigneusement
gratter fouillé nous n'irons trouvé
aucun trucage apparent
tessier
le projet implique et l'émotion d'abord
jean faire tomber
je fais passer le plan par trois styles
différents et je prenne un quatrième
élément et le blanc le métal ville
devient à l'autre sous l'effet de la
poudre de religion
c'est une expérience qui peut être très
dangereuse y ait des dangereux
voulez vous des sénateurs
très peu progressé
vous êtes là totalement m une expérience
complètement aucun danger aucun danger
c'est une odeur de
de bain joueurs avez-vous senti le
benjoin parti pour elle nous avons quand
même le saisir car la femme est trop
tard
regardez bien cette main qui tient le
couteau nous ne l'avons pas quitter des
yeux de toute l'expérience et jamais
elle n'a touché le creuset
maintenant il faut arrêter complètement
la nouvelle à la vie
prenez le
vous allez le maître dessus de l'eau au
dessus seulement nous avons perdu du
méthane et vous allez le lâcher en le
faisant en le faisant tomber sur le côté
ou sur l'eau mais pas à plat
sur le côté mal à lâcher le
il est froid
c'est le quart de métal perdu ces
petites boules et ça
j'aime aussi et andreu se réveille au
le plomb qui est journaux maintenant
se tenant
nature c'était
ce métal jaune nous l'avons fait
expertiser
il avait exactement le même diamètre que
notre fils de plomb diamètre que nous
étions seuls à connaître
le fil à supporter le
phénomène de la coopération avec
[Musique]
trucage ou non il a donc réussi son
entrée en scène
il a excité notre curiosité
il sait que maintenant nous l'écoutons
pour les gens qui
sont initiés à cet ordre d'idées je dis
idées à bonne escient ce qu'ils ont lu
certains ouvrages qui ont été faits sur
moi je suis en alchimiste et le dernier
des templiers
je bénéficie d'un produit
qui est issue d'une technique et d'une
science qui me permet de traverser le
temps
et qui me permet également
de me présenter aujourd'hui au même
titre qu'il y à 400 ou 500 années
sous le nom du comte de saint germain
actuellement nous sommes 12
et quand je dis actuellement ça implique
une durée de plusieurs milliers d'années
je suis le seul en france
et dans quelques semaines
flamel dur à me rejoindre ici il
représente pour nous un des douze
connaissance il est notre maître à tous
quand il à savoir plus poussé que le
vôtre oui c'est certain actuellement
lorsque je vous parle je suis en
relation avec quatre personnes devant
lui en ce moment actuellement vous les
entendez moi je les entends pas vous
nous entendez pas
peut-être pas encore c'est pourquoi j'ai
beaucoup de difficulté à pareil il vous
dit ce qu'il faut dire ce qu'il ne faut
pas dire et vous les interrogez
permettez moi de douter
[Musique]
à part ça
le comte de saint germain de l'histoire
lui ressemble et boum il avait son
allure son talent de conteur sa vaste
culture ses connaissances historiques il
émerveillé lui aussi avec des prodiges
de salon
on lui attribue la fabrication par
alchimie du régent un diamant de 130
carats il sauva dit-on la fortune de
louis 15 il fut au coeur des grandes
intrigues internationale il se disait
fondateur d rose croix
voltaire l'appeler l'homme qui sait tout
et qui ne meurt jamais se parlent dit
cette maman les médias l'acte
et que faites vous par exemple que je ne
fasse pas de là et je vis longtemps et
encore
c'est beaucoup c'est
vrai nous un homme qui a eu un très
grave accident que je sais moi qui vous
êtes vous êtes une ancienne vedette du
monde du spectacle dansé lgv est connu
vous avez quitté le spectacle
vous avez maintenant une situation dans
l'industrie importante c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous ne voulais pas
montrer un autre visage
dans quelles circonstances vous avez
rencontré le pont de saint germain et
comment vous utilisiez et bien c'est
très simple et j'ai eu l'opportunité de
faire sa connaissance
la suite pourrait nous avons plus ou
moins
baptisé
et
j'ai donc l'accident faisait parler tout
à l'heure je suis dit quel j'ai perdu un
oeil
et jason bourne un jour nous en avons
parlé et il m'a dit à quel point ces
deux foyen un jour tout s'arrangera
saint-germain m'a fait prendre certains
produits le lendemain je voyais
normalement avec mes deux yeux alors que
j'étais parfaitement banques et tous les
professeurs de paris d'europe pour vous
confirmer travel apic j'étais borgne et
mon oeil était mort mort mort à 100%
[Musique]
sa vie quotidienne la cache il se dit
antiquaires mais il n'est jamais dans
son magasin on le prétend très occupé
mais ils se libèrent facilement il
refuse de donner son adresse je n'aime
pas chez moi comme chaque français je
pense mais un peu plus puisque j'ai le
temps
est-ce que vous avez des souvenirs on en
venait là aujourd'hui avec mozart à
versailles et souvenirs qui reviennent
en vous évidemment je ne dirais pas
chaque armement représente quelque chose
chaque bassin chaque statuette mais il
est vrai que cette foule qui n'est plus
là sont quand même présents dans mon
esprit
et je vous avoue que certains sports je
retrouve certaines personnes dans ce
parc
madame de prix
[Musique]
vous verrez que je sois et tenait bien
sûr votre réaction inverse est étonné
moi-même
cette personne que j'ai gardées à l'âge
de 24 ans
qui a bénéficié de mon produit
et que j'ai récupéré et réintégré lors
de sa mort à l'état actuel c'est à dire
l'état d'une très très jolie femme c'est
vrai c'est vrai aussi
le bo aurait été atteint au xviiie
siècle
et ne s'est jamais dépassé
12 15 et nous avons regardé qui vit dans
midi de la france portait un grand
sentiment la dame de lourdes à nouveau
ne pouvait pas
continuer avec nous cette aventure
sans madame de pompadour
même y voit le roi 4 fois par mois
et pour la dernière fois cette année
haydn rock vous avez passé les vacances
ensemble nous avons passé 14 jours
ensemble oui des vacances très xxème
siècle e place le bateau automobile
night club le roi s'habitue bien on
accole
north one s'habitue pas ce genre de
choses il aime à dîner chez des amis car
il a de nombreux amis sur la côte et
dans le milieu de la france mais il
n'aime pas tellement
jerk
pour employer le jerk enveloppe
une déformation de cette époque
à chacun semble venu comme disait madame
de leur enclos
cette échappée a servi deux fois
d'entrevues dans le roi avec madame de
contact
sofia tout une demeure qui m'a pas
retenu c'était un relais
entre le monde et le temps
à
employait des expériences
sur les les animaux je dois le dire
parce que un jour ou l'autre je
l'écrirai cette chose
sur les insectes notamment j'avais un
temps de 17 kg
qui vivaient dans ce bâtiment
actuellement la porte est fermée
[Musique]
apparemment hormis ces portails rien n'a
changé
cette antenne de télévision sur le toit
aujourd'hui au xxème siècle c'est un des
plus gros industriels en électronique
d'europe et je sais que c'est vrai il
veut pas qu'on voit
c'est casanova j'ai rencontré saint
germain dans une ville que nous
connaissons tous qui s'appelle chartres
on est venu me voir me trouvais en
m'expliquant qui jetait ce que je fais
ce que je représentais est ce que je
pourrais représentés et bien entendu
j'étais sceptique il m'a demandé de le
suivre nous avons
parcouru
quelques kilomètres quelques kilomètres
est la chose la plus extraordinaire qui
puisse arriver à quelqu'un comme moi ou
comme comme une personne l'autre est
arrivé j'ai vu une chose extraordinaire
quoi je vais un bois se soulever
faute et je m'en rappelle simplement des
modes de terre qui était qui était
accroché à ses armes et qui faisait au
moins trois mètres de haut nous avons
montré un espèce de chemin qu'ils
quitteront pourrait appeler un tunnel ce
que vous voulez la porte du temps la
porte de ma connu la porte du temps
puisque vous appelez le fantastique il
nous sommes arrivés dans une salle
immense une salle d'une mince avec des
appareils des appareils qui avaient une
forme ronde qui sont très très grand je
ne pouvais plus parler je savais plus
quoi dire je ne savais plus
nous sommes entrés dans un de ces
appareils et jai vue pas sous une forme
des trans
une paroisse de métal j'ai eu ma vie
sanary culte j'ai vécu une vie ce que
ce que j'étais vous avez eu kazan oeuvre
j'ai vu casanova dans toutes les
périodes de sa vie je me suis vieux
riches très riches je me suis dis pauvre
je me suis vraiment prison
vous est devenu amoureux sans doute
les trois quarts du temps oui
cette lan m'a pas retenu à la fin du
xixème siècle
et puis
à la suite de nombreux déménagements jeu
les gars et il ya peu de temps et de mes
amis
on a fait cadeau
car il avait reconnu sur le pommeau de
la can des chiffres qui gérait marquer
il est au courant de ceci bien entendu
une canne fusible état de marche
dit le percuteur étant dans le manche
c'est du neuf ou dix bateaux
[Musique]
nous venons de ce que vous appelez
les sommes actuelles appellent
l'atlantide
l'atlantide kit est
un continent
[Musique]
et sur ce continent a été construite une
ville immense
serpent dont et lyon
lorsque le satellite naturel
qui remplaçait par la lune actuelle
[Musique]
s'est rapproché de la terre de la
planète
les dernières personnes habitant
l'atlantide
j'emploie le mot moderne habitants et
lyon
sont partis sur des atolls chez nos
appareils
pour mars
[Musique]
nous avons reconstruit une base ce qui
s'appelle un lionceau mars je n'étais
pas né à l'épaule ses parents y avait
une structure différente de la vôtre qui
réelle d'un salaire environ trois fois
la taille que vous faites actuellement
on construit cette base
ils sont revenus
sur cette planète
avec les mêmes appareils nous avons subi
un cataclysme je suis retourné
personnellement sur mars
la base existe toujours dans peu de
temps
dans un temps assez proche du nôtre vous
retrouverez les vestiges de la face
votre base actuelle ces chartes mais
c'est un endroit précis de chartres la
cathédrale par exemple
la cathédrale
se trouve la première entrée de la base
effectivement cela correspond au centre
du labyrinthe de la 4 g
et
[Musique]
votre fortune aujourd'hui c'est toujours
celle du xviiie que vous entretenez si
on veut oui c'est exact c'est un peu ça
baisser la fortune de mon art aussi on
ne me laisse pas dans la misère pas tout
le temps ces votes rendre qui qui vous
entretien avec sa supérieure et
j'entretiens les autres
[Musique]
ce sont tous mes frais de déplacement
voyez que mon ordre men et dans l'espace
ans on nous avait pourtant dit que vous
étiez un espion mais ses formes on dit
tellement de choses
on dit tellement de choses on dit bien
je suis morte elle aussi
[Musique]
nous avons réussi à connaître son état
civil mais il ne s'est pas démonté pour
autant il prétend qu'il a mystifié ses
parents légaux en usurpant la place d'un
disparu il a une adresse
mais il n'y habitent pas qui tenait la
boutique d'antiquités du vendéen germain
exactement vous connaissez contre s'agir
du corps aime tant se fait 28 ans
exactement 28 ans ce son est assez vide
il a 30 ans il avait qui la jalonnent le
remonter eh bien je vais vous dire je
les ai connus pour vous dire vraiment
l'époque où il est né je ne sais pas
mais je l' ai connu exactement comme il
est maintenant il n'a jamais changé à 28
ans il a toujours le même j'ai toujours
trouvé avec le même physique
la vérité dans le temps ces figures de
mensonges
vous vivez avec le fantastique tous les
jours vous ne vous étonnez pas que cette
caméra gardera cette parole gardera
cette image si je vous dis que fait
traverser le temps
avec mon produit
la pierre philosophale
si vous voulez appelons la comme ça ou
la poudre de projets xi mapou de
reproduction ou 7 antimatière c'est de
l'esprit malatya l'esprit de la matière
est un est une anguille matière est un
élément
au même titre que cette caméra est un
élément pour me garder pour vous garder
dans le temps pour garder un souvenir ou
mais le temps vous gardent encore plus
longtemps que vous gardera cette caméra
c'est pour ça que je voudrais vous
demander quel est votre technique de
survie
comment êtes vous devenu immortel par
quels moyens
ça je ne peux pas pu expliquer
et pourtant ça qui est intéressant
la seule chose qui importe interrogé
interrogez vos quatre compagnons avec
qui vous êtes en relation pour savoir si
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus
et vous en répondu ben non ils n'ont pas
répondu
est ce que vous avez voulu convaincre
absolument pas c'est du groupe
d'ailleurs je doute que quelqu'un soit
convaincu on s'attend à beaucoup de
choses et on ne s'attend pas à ce qu'un
homme
puisse dire ce que j'ai dit tout en
ayant l'apparence d'un homme vous même
si par par un heureux hasard ou par une
heureuse coïncidence vous bénéficiez
d'une certaine quantité de produit et
que dans un siècle dans deux siècles
vous disiez devant une caméra de
télévision
et bien aujourd'hui je vous dis que j'ai
habité ici j'ai fait une émission avec
monsieur de saint germain que voici
voici monsieur ferme mac au cas où vous
seriez passé dans la postérité dans cent
ans on ne vous parlera pas
peut-être pensé vous n'aurez rien à dire
aussi
[Musique]
il a fait il fait peut-être encore de la
politique il ne dissimule pas ses choix
il reconnaît avoir fait de la prison
pour participation à l'oas il admet
volontiers des sympathies nazies c'est
semble-t-il dans la logique d'un
personnage qui croient à un ordre au
rôle prédestiné d'une et le sujet de
cette émission
c'est pour montrer comme nous l'avons
fait cinq fois déjà
que les temps sont venus le dernier
signe s'accomplir dans les dix années à
venir
le quatrième singh pour nous je vous en
donne l'explication
a été l'emploi de l'atome
l'homme en 1945
détruire ce qu'il avait construit à des
fins destructrices
pour s'exterminer
notre intervention a joué en 1939 les
chefs d'état s'étaient pas quand tu
étais je contactais prévenu
averti
et aujourd'hui la même opération
beaucoup plus épouvantable va se répéter
dans un temps qui est très proche pour
vous et pour moi puisque nous sommes
dans le temps avec le temps
la solution viendra de par nous et
lorsque le temps s'arrêtera
[Musique]
ceux qui l'écoutent préfère ne retenir
qu'un beau récit pour alimenter leurs
rêves
il trouve aussi peut-être dans ces
propos un écho à leurs inquiétudes
l'inquiétude d'un temps à l'avenir
incertain
vous est ce que vous avez peur de la
mort je ne la connais pas
mais un jour vous la connaîtrez
peut-être peut-être alors comment vous
la voyez cette mort
je ne vois pas je ne la connais pas mais
si elle doit être vécue alors je pense
que nous vivons une mort actuellement
[Musique]